now somehow this capacity we have that
makes us human there's some respect in
which we are all created equal and where
I think that is is this phenomenon of
the dogs and the kids dogs at various
times in their lives are greatly
preferable to children right but they're
not the same kind of thing else they
would say so and they never do right
last night the dogs were talking to us
as dogs talking right and Aristotle says
animals use their voices to indicate
pleasure and pain people speak to
distinguish the just from the unjust
right this whole thing is a statement of
the just and the unjust and it depends
on this simple point this is what all
men are created equal means you are the
King of England and you ride in a golden
carriage and everybody salutes you and
all fear you but you know when you were
a year-and-a-half old you started doing
something that no animal has ever done
and no one taught you to do that you
just started doing it and it wasn't
because you were born royal it's because
you were born human and so were we
it just means that and they think what
that allows our kids like